hey guys after a few promo teasers that
revealed only the premiere date end
after the last promo which provided the
first official look of the Kings and the
Queen's yesterday HBO has released more
than a few promotional photos from the
seventh season to be exact 15
promotional photos have been released in
those 15 photos we can see 20 characters
in their new costumes well most of them
are also locations they've never been
before let's start with a photo in which
we can see Arya Stark while the certain
location is unknown depending on the
episode from which it's taken if this
photo is taken from the scene which we
are going to see in the middle or final
episodes of the upcoming season it might
be in the north and Winterfell but if
this photo is from the scene that we're
going to see in the first episodes it
can also be in Riverland since in her
final scene aura killed Walder Frey and
his two sons well there's a big
possibility of her killing the remaining
phrase by using the face she gets thrown
from the Hall of faces or even with the
face of Walder Frey I know that if you
haven't watched all of my videos it
might sound out of the realm of
possibilities but a few months ago it's
been revealed that according to the
official agency resume of an actor David
Bradley to us known as Walder Frey will
appear in the upcoming season or Game of
Thrones
however Walder Frey is not coming back
his throat had been slit open he is dead
but are you start wearing bowlers face
to kill remaining phrase would explain
why nectar that portrays Walder Frey was
according to his agency resume filming
scenes for the seventh season if Ari
will truly kill every single Frey
denarii and his photo might be at
Riverrun
the former seat of house Tully is upon
killing the phrase she would most likely
release her uncle Edmure Tully who is
phrase prisoner situated in one of the
cells as well Frey mentioned himself on
the celebration in the next photo we can
clearly see Jaime protecting the new
ruler and if we can even call her the
protector of the Seven Kingdoms which
might be surprising for most of us as
many fans thought the Jaime's going to
turn his back on Cersei after if seeing
his final scene in season six in me
Jaime entered the iron throne room and
witnessed Cersei being proclaimed as a
new queen of the Seven Kingdoms
since his face expression while he was
looking at Cersei sitting on the throne
was full of anger full of disdain but as
I've said in my video about James fate
in the upcoming season Jaime's Lannister
and as
photos confirmed he will continue
fighting to improve lancers position but
the relationship between those two
siblings lovers won't stay the same as
it had been back in previous seasons
Jaime will not look at Cersei as he once
had he will not feel any well towards
Cersei anymore the relationship will be
based only on formality which is the
result of Cersei using wildfire to kill
her enemies which would not concern
Jamie if Cersei didn't also kill a lot
of innocent people the same people that
Jaime was protected from the Mad King by
killing the same King the king whom he
was supposed to protect with his own
life and beside his fact the same
Circe's act also resulted with their
son's suicide in conclusion Jaime's
relationship with her civil most
probably based on formality while
there's a big possibility of Jaime
killing his ones beloved sister and
lover Cersei on the wedding night upon a
few Cersei decisions that will make
Jaime speechless which theory of mine
you can check out in one of my previous
videos entitled new red wedding in
season 7 however sirs his new outfit
looks stunning similar to her season 6
finale outfit the next photo contains
Daenerys Targaryen along with her
advisors Varys and Miss sandy her hen
tyrion lannister and the commander of
her arm in great form at Dragonstone
which at this point is not surprising at
all as the official promo that HP
released a few weeks ago has already
confirmed that the nurse who land a
dragon stone on the east coast of
Westeros the ancestral seat of House
Targaryen but a few scenes of dinners
walking through the halls of Dragonstone
burp on she entered the throne room and
sat on the throne
however beside their new stunning darker
outfits beside the nurses amazing dress
with dragon motifs there's something
more interesting that can be seen on
this photo which is their face
expressions and the position of their
eyes their most probable looking at the
Dragons flying above dragon stone which
is doubtlessly going to be an amazing
scene there's also photo of Sandor
Clegane travelling north with the
Brotherhood without banners which beside
his new outfit is nothing new or
surprising since the Brotherhood in
their last appearance in the previous
season in the 8th episode of the sixth
season revealed their intention of
travelling north to fight against the
night King and his undead army let's
continue with a photo which contains
similarly and Gilly clearly studying at
Citadel well the most important thing
about is for
is that gillies reading about azor Ahai
reading a page from the world of Ice and
Fire book that every single one of us
actually can buy that book is fully
illustrated history compendium of
Martin's fictional Westeros written from
the perspective of an in world master
while gillies reading about azor Ahai
and all Sam is learning about history
healing and strategy at the world's
greatest library Sam story in season
seven will be even more interesting if
Jorah comes to seek help at the old town
as it is the site of the Citadel which
would not be surprising since main stars
and healers managed to cure the daughter
of Stannis Baratheon who was infected by
this same disease and also there's a
confirmation that jim broadbent the
Academy of interactive Allah peer in the
upcoming season and play his role as an
arch maester which an actor confirmed
himself in an interview with screen
crush with statement I'm a maester an
arch maester I'm an old professor
character beside his confirmation
broadband also confirmed his appearance
in five episodes with one major scene in
each episodes as he said I did sort of a
major scene in each episode with all of
this being said it's easy to assume that
Jim Broadbent will appear as ebro's an
archmaester the Citadel who tests
novices seeking their link in the art of
healing well it's also important to
highlight broadband statement that his
scenes were shared with John Bradley an
actor that plays similarly with all of
those confirmations along with leaked
photos that are confirming jurors
greyscale being cured there's certainly
a possibility that Sam and their
brothers will discover cure forgers
greyscale will cure John's grayscale and
also if you're interested in details
about jim broadbent mysterious role feel
free to check out my previous videos
let's continue with a photo that
includes Meera Reed and bran stark
while at first glance it looks just like
another scene of Meera pooling brand
summer beyond wall considering
expressions on their faces and
considering that both of them are
clearly looking at something really high
they might have finally reached the wall
which is not a big surprise especially
after the last promo series which
revealed brands new outfit which in my
opinion is the official confirmation
that bran stark will finally reunited
his siblings and Winterfell at some
point of the upcoming season since those
outfits used in that promo series are
also used in filming the seventh season
photos and the first official photos
from the seventh season are confirming
long story short Brandon finally
reunited his family beside those photos
there are also photos of Lyanna Mormont
and our sievert at Winterfell probably
discussing with the king in the north
about the fate of treasonist norton
houses let's continue with a photo of
Petyr Baelish and sense a stark at
Winterfell an interesting photo which is
once again confirming that Littlefinger
skilled manipulator and the most cunning
man in Seven Kingdoms will not stop with
his attempts to manipulate Sansa Baelish
demanded betrayed Ned Stark in order to
set up a fight between wolf's alliance
demanded poison Joffrey Lannister and
Geoffrey's own wedding with the
assistance of Allah natural to save
Sansa Stark and then that same girl
already tortured by Lannisters was
handed over to even more sick oppressor
Ramsay Bolton all in order to turn the
North against Bolton's and to give him
an opportunity to set Sansa as the queen
in the north
the man that first married and then
killed Liza rain and now he's
manipulating with her son robbing all in
order to have the power over the Vale
all of this Littlefinger played in order
to bring back Winterfell to Sansa Stark
which he managed to accomplish but even
now when his main plan to get sense as
the ruler of interval and as the Queen
in the north failed Littlefinger the man
that made all of these actions
regardless on the pain that he brought
to many people this man Petyr Baelish
will doubtlessly give his best to make
his plans come true we'll try to achieve
his goal that he has imagined a picture
of him sitting on the Iron Throne with
sense about his side but that might lead
him to his death in my opinion send
someone be manipulated by Baelish since
she doesn't trust him as she said
herself only a fool would trust
Littlefinger well there's also almost a
confirmed fact that our evil reunite
with your family at Winterfell
but before she arrives to her home
she'll most probably have a few
encounters of which one with the
Brotherhood without banners whose new
member the hound might reveal the truth
to Arya the truth about Littlefinger's
betrayal over her father Ned however if
you would like to hear more details
about a theory in which Starks sisters
will orchestrate death of Littlefinger
feel free to check out either a video
man by the name season 7 confirmed
deaths or a video by the name
Littlefinger spade in season 7 there
also photos of various
sending their new already mentioned
outfits which can also be seen previous
promo teasers and in a lot of leaked
photos taken a months ago the next photo
contains the matter of dragons
Daenerys Targaryen Indian throne room at
Dragonstone probably having a meeting
with someone with Jon Snow in my opinion
since their meeting had been confirmed a
long time ago let's continue with a
photo that includes Jon Snow this photo
is the most interesting photo of all of
them since Jon Snow is most probably
below interval in the crypt of
Winterfell probably visiting recon stump
and the tons of other members of his
family which would not be that
interesting but there are a few popular
theories fooling around about the Crypt
according to which Jon will not be told
who his real parents are by brand stark
or Howland Reed but we'll find it out by
himself as according to these theories
Ned hid a hint for Jon's summer in the
crypt the last photo is pretty funny as
it contains torment will probably be
once again rejected by Brienne but hey
this is Game of Thrones everything is
possible let me know your opinion about
those 15 promotional photos that
provided us 20 characters so which most
of them are in your outfits and the
locations they've never been before I
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see you in the
next one peace
[Music]